ma vie zoo les énergivores gros
émetteurs de co2 la chasse aux passoire
thermique est bel et bien lancée pour
joe carrington merci d'être avec nous
juristes et experts en immobilier
comment on arrive déjà ce chiffre de 5
millions de passoires thermiques en
france parce que c'est le chiffre qui
est avancé pour le coup par l'état mais
quand on écoute beaucoup d'experts on a
parfois le chiffre de 6,7 millions de
passoires thermiques en france alors là
actuellement en fait il ya eu une petite
chose qu'on a oublié en même temps que
la joie climat c'est le changement du
dpe et le changement
est en fait cette modification qui
soi-disant le rend plus sûrs change en
fait des critères et ce changement de
critères ça joue sur les chiffres et
donc on a quand même alors on se
rapprocherait plus des 7 millions mais
eux la problématique c'est qu'il
faudrait faire faire un dpe à toutes les
maisons tous les appart et ça c'est
encore pas fait qu'elle ait définition
concrètement d'une passoire thermique
alors c'est un logement énergivore mais
pas que parce que on oublie aussi que
c'est un logement qui est polluant en
émissions de co2 donc un logement qui
est une passoire thermique il a la note
c'est sa f ou g ses seins alors oui
aujourd'hui c'est ça c'est f ou g et
demain donc 2025 ce sera aussi eu voilà
et si on est chauffé au fioul par
exemple conçoit des ronds dans un
logement collectif eau ou en maison
individuelle est ce qu'on est
nécessairement considéré pour le coup
comme une passoire énergétique alors pas
vraiment énergétique mais on est plutôt
polluants en fait parce qu'on a des
maisons neuves qui sont chauffées au
fioul
mais par contre derrière est comme ils
ont une chaudière plus le fuel pas bon
et bien elles sont polluantes voilà
après donc il ya les nouvelles
réglementations qui ont été votées
récemment et là on vit avec cette loi
climat et résidences que peut-être les
jours des passoires thermiques sans
compter on pas studios opèrent en france
alors
que c'est une tendance
est ce que aujourd'hui ce qui est sur la
sellette c'est les locations et les
ventes parce que tous les propriétaires
qui vendent pas ou qu'ils nous pas en
fait ils sont pas concernés par la loi
climat pour le moment parce que le
gouvernement donc a décidé d'interdire à
la location les logements donc
énergivores e f et g dès 2025 pour les
logements j'ai hélas on dit que c'est
d'avancer dans trois ans quand
ça change la donne rome alors ça change
la veux dire aux gens vous pouvez pas
mettre en location alors ça change la
donne parce que enfin oui et non parce
que ben quand on avait envie de faire
des travaux ben on va ça va être le
moment de le faire donc on va se lancer
après quand on n'avait pas les moyens de
faire des travaux ça va être compliqué
parce que faut reconnaître que sortir un
logement de l'état de passoires
thermiques et basse à un coût certain
dit entre 40000 60000 euros et il faut
il ya une lettre publique mesquida
publique telle qu'elle existe
aujourd'hui sera longtemps imprimé
renner est ce qu'elle est suffisante
alors l aide on fait quand même partie
des pays où on aide le plus par contre
quand on n'a pas les moyens de faire des
travaux et souvent on achète un bien
qu'ils avaient une mauvaise note parce
que on n'avait que les moyens d'acheter
ce type de bien là est bon on n'a pas
plus les moyens de faire les travaux
derrière et qu'on ait une prime ou pas
ah c'est toujours très compliqué même si
les français quand on regarde les
chiffres carlington rénove de plus en
plus leur logement 750 mille logements
rénovés l'an dernier c'est du jamais vu
et donc on se dit que pour le coup les
aides à la rénovation cedomir d'euros
qui parce que ça coûte au budget de
l'état pour l'imprimerie nov c'est peut
être en train de changer un petit peu
les mentalités alors l'idée elle est
vraiment là elle les deux changé les
mentalités elle est surtout de faire
rénover mieux en fait est d'inciter les
gens à ne pas faire j'allais dire de
bric et de broc de vraiment faire une
rénovation qui tient la route et qui
écologiquement et positive qui tient la
route qui coûte cher ah oui
obligatoirement on peut très bien aussi
faire des travaux de rénovation est
malgré tout resté classé f ou g malgré
les travaux qu'on a fait alors tout
dépend ce qu'on fait comme travaux
quels sont les principaux appels pour
être sûr de pour sortir de cet état de
passoires thermiques absolument alors
les principaux ça va toujours touchés
l'isolation les ouvrants et puis donc
fait notre ouïe porte le nahd bardon et
puis également les chaudières et on
oublie un petit peu c'est la ventilation
un v m c'est parce que plus un air est
humide plus les difficiles à chauffer et
il ya beaucoup de logements qui sont mal
ventilée et donc du coup ça pose une
problématique de chauffage et derrière
ce sont des logements qui sont
énergivores donc plusieurs dizaines de
milliers d'euros pour faire sortir un
engagement de l'état de passoires
thermiques à ça bon après on dit que
enfin en temps on n'entend que de
beaucoup de propriétaires de passoires
thermiques j'entends préfèrent vendre
leur logement plutôt que de les rénover
il ya une vraie tendance là dessus aussi
parce que alors demain en fait après
demain 2025 enfin même la
2022 1er septembre 2022 en fait on va
avoir au moment de la vente qu'on
appelle un audit énergétique et cet
audit énergétique va faire une enveloppe
travaux qui va porter en fait j'allais
dire qui va peser sur la valeur du bien
et donc derrière c'est vrai que les gens
craignent ce qui n'est pas tout à fait
vrai en fait il entend d'ailleurs ceux
qui préfèrent plutôt vendre que de faire
ces travaux de rénovation bah oui des
fois ils ont plutôt parce que en fait
ils ont plus intérêt à faire ces travaux
et à continuer donc de tirer parti de
leur bien que de vendre et de racheter
parce qu'on va avoir au bout d'un moment
de moins en moins en fait de bien qui
sont classés ab est de plus en plus de
bien classés fg donc c'est à dire qu'à
une décote aujourd'hui sur les prix des
logements qui sont fg notamment j'ai
passoires thermiques par rapport à un
gars qui serait performant j'en veux
dire est énergétiquement alors décote
une décote oui plutôt que des coach
préfère parler d' enveloppe travaux
parce que
bon souvent mais un chiffre un
pourcentage est la difficulté avec un
pourcentage c'est que derrière pour
chaque logement on est sur des travaux
différents et puis ça va dépendre aussi
de la pression foncière donc en fait on
va pas avoir le j'allais dire le même la
même problématique pour de logements
différents et donc effectivement il faut
prévoir une enveloppe travaux et
certains estiment que chaque classe fait
baisser en gros 2 5 % le prix d'un
logement quand on descend en dfg c'est
vrai j'ai toujours du mal avec ces
chiffres aulas et j'allais dire c'est
une moyenne et dès l'instant que c'est
une moyenne en fait il ya des ya des cas
où ça ne sera pas ce sera pas vrai
notamment quand on habite dans le nord
de la france et quand on habite dans le
sud de la france en fait on n'aura pas
le même impact sur le prix et donc un
logement qui est performant
énergétiquement a contrario il va se
vendre au mieux plus vite
tout entendu des finances des gens en
tout cas cette loi encore une fois il ya
l'idée que les passoires thermiques
aujourd'hui sont dans le viseur des
autorités c'est ça oui c'est exactement
ça en fait là c'est vraiment la loi qui
va accélérer la lutte contre contre la
consommation énergétique puisque on est
quand même sur 45 % de concept de
consommation énergétique dans le
logement et puis la pollution par le
dégagement de co2
enfin c'est un quart des dégagements
touchent donc ça dans mon sens c'est
tant mieux merci beaucoup carlington
qu'un juriste et expert en immobilier
alors de nouvelles contraintes dans
l'ancien la vie mais également de
nouvelles normes environnementales pour
les logements neufs vous allez voir
[Musique]